you know one of the things that I've
been struck very hard by a number of
writers Carl young obviously among them
I mean he he wrote things like Nietzsche
that if you understand them they just
break you into pieces you know and and
one of the things that Jung understood
in the psychoanalysts understand it's
one of the most terrifying elements of
psychoanalytic thinking is very tightly
allied with religious thinking which is
that you are not the master of your own
house there are spirits that dwell in
you within you meaning you have a will
and you can exercise a certain amount of
conscious control over your being but
there are all sorts of things that occur
within you that seem to be beyond your
capacity to control your dreams for
example that's a really good example or
your impulses for example you might you
might think of those as so foreign from
you that they're not even you don't even
want them to be part of you but but more
subtly even how about what you're
interested in what compels you like
where does that come from exactly
because you can't you can't conjure it
up of your own accord you know so if
you're a student and you're taking
difficult course you might say to
yourself well I need to sit down and
study for three hours but then you sit
down and that is what happens your
attention goes everywhere and you might
say well whose attention is it then if
it goes everywhere because you say it's
your attention it's like well if it's
your attention maybe you'd be able to
control it but you can't and so then you
might think well Jen and just exactly
what the hell is controlling it and you
might say well it's random it's the well
it better not be random I can tell you
that that's that happens to some degree
in schizophrenia there's an element of
randomness and that it's not random
it's driven by the action of phenomena
that I think are best considered as
something like subpersonalities although
even that's only a partial description
you can't make yourself interested in
something interest manifests itself and
grips you that's a whole different thing
and so what is it that's gripping you
and how do you conceptualize that is
that a divine power
well it's divine as far as you're
concerned because it grips you and you
can't do anything about it and so
there's a
falling in you towards what you're
compelled by and what you're interested
in is sometimes that might be very dark
and sometimes not but you're compelled
forward by your interest and so and so
the idea that what moves you away from
your country in your father's house and
the comforts of your child at home is is
something that's beyond you and that you
listen to and hearken to that's exactly
right and you can say well I don't want
to call that God it's like it doesn't
matter what you call it
exactly it doesn't matter to what it is
what it's called it still is and if you
don't listen to it that's the other
thing if you don't listen to it and I've
been a clinician and talked to enough
people now as old as I am to know this
absolutely if you do not listen to that
thing that beckons you forward you will
pay for it like you cannot possibly
imagine you'll have everything that's
terrible about life in your life and
nothing about it that's good and worse
you'll know that it was your fault and
that you squandered what you could have
had